in 2009 district nine became the
surprise hit movie of the year on a
budget of just thirty million dollars
the movie went on to make 210 million
dollars at the worldwide box office and
was nominated for four Academy Awards
including Best Motion Picture although
it didn't win any Oscars district nine
breakout success was an impressive feat
for an indie sci-fi film out of South
Africa with a first-time writer director
that featured no movie stars so why
wasn't a sequel to district 9 ever made
here's why a standalone story according
to district 9 mastermind Neill Blomkamp
he wasn't even thinking about making a
sequel while writing directing and
editing the film since Blomkamp was only
planning on making a standalone film he
didn't set up the overall story arc for
a sequel or a franchise it was only
after the film was edited that Blomkamp
realized there was room for a sequel but
he still had no idea where that sequel
would go he also told around with making
a prequel instead Blomkamp told hero
complex in 2010 I'm not so interested in
aliens coming back and blowing things up
but a prequel might be interesting
obviously the idea never left the ground
either and it wasn't until 2015 that
Blomkamp said that he had a really cool
idea for a district 9 sequel does that
mean that a sequel is finally on the way
at the moment it doesn't look likely
original films in a perfect world
production on a district 9 sequel would
have started shortly after the first one
was released however without an idea for
the sequel Blum comes instead he used
the success of district 9 to get another
original sci-fi film into production
with a month of district nines release
that movie was Elysium which he worked
on until late 2012 while shooting
Elysium Blomkamp and his wife / co
screenwriter Terri Tatchell wrote the
script for chappie in two weeks and
after Elysium wrapped they immediately
started working on bat production on
that movie lasted into 2014 and it was
released in theaters in February 2015 so
yeah those movies kept a Blomkamp pretty
busy poster district 9 Blomkamp told
Rolling Stone that if he were to do the
sequel properly it would take three
years to make that's a big time
commitment or while the movie that set
it all off recedes into fans
Marie's other projects chappie was
released in May 2015 and although there
hasn't been much news about the director
since then Blomkamp has definitely been
busy in April 2017 Blomkamp revealed on
Twitter that he would be making
experimental short films for the video
game platform steam that's a big change
from big-budget sci-fi flicks although
at this point in his career it's
certainly less risky than taking a
chance on a sequel to district 9
Blomkamp was also briefly attached to
director fifth entry in the alien series
going so far as to release tantalizing
an official concept art on instagram but
unfortunately that project probably
isn't happening in 2017 a Blomkamp
tweeted the awful truth the chances of
his alien movie ever moving forward are
slim
echoing an earlier tweet that the movie
was satisfied pending the success of
failure of alien covenant that doesn't
mean that Blomkamp's blockbuster days
are over
after all this wouldn't be the first
time plumb cam has bounced back after
being sidelined on a high-profile film
project originally Blomkamp was picked
by Peter Jackson to direct a movie based
on the Halo video game franchise when
halo fell through Jackson agreed to
produce district 9 based on Blomkamp's
2006 short film alive in joburg in other
words the faceless Blomkamp hasn't made
a movie for several years now it doesn't
mean that a district 9 sequel will never
happen although it seems to be getting
less and less likely also Coakley is
busy too although he looks different at
the end of the film
she also Coakley is the face of district
9 in his breakout role as a delightfully
clueless bureaucrat
a South African actor wowed
international audiences and lost his
Hollywood career but I don't trust it
you know I don't touch meaningless your
actress because you're at after choppy
Copley's third collaboration with Neill
Blomkamp the accent on to star in the
PlayStation series powers and the action
thriller free fire as busy as he is
though copeley has made it clear that
he'd gladly reprised his role if a
district 9 sequel ever materialized
hard to follow up district 9 ended on a
cliffhanger and the universe of the film
is rich with themes and storylines to
explore cope
wants to do a sequel and the movie was a
huge success for Peter Jackson's
production company in Hollywood that
combination usually adds up to a
guaranteed sequel and yes the furthest
in development that District nine sequel
ever got was an 18-page treatment one
reason for that may be because district
9 was too big of a hit its commentary on
social segregation xenophobia and racism
blended perfectly with its sci-fi
aesthetic all of which helped it make it
an overwhelming success for the first
time writer director that's the hard act
to follow even when the actor you're
following is your own thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]